if someone yells gangway what do they
want you to do and get out of the way
get out the way get out the way this is
my friend Michael do you remember that
one time when Michael came over to visit
me in England that I taught him how to
speak like a British person I don't even
understand what you're saying
well this here surrounding me is America
specifically Michaels house so while I'm
here he's going to get his own back by
trying to teach me some of that America
talk enjoy what is a caboose is that a
large bottom that is a the last car on a
train isn't it also bottom it can be
slang for a woman's rear end because
it's the rear of a train so it's like
okay what happens if you get something
on a mode a la mode like the Muslim goat
Allah like a la mode activate yeah it
means it comes with ice-cream that one
would have made more sense if I'd seen
it written down I went straight for yeah
deities if I acquired something with a
five finger discount what does that mean
oh that means that you stole it I sure
we have that one in the UK the internet
said you didn't oh well this is the
thing you need to learn about the
Internet is that not everything on the
internet is true if your friend's car is
a beater what kind of car is it a beta
is it better than all of the other cows
because anything fits them yes no
actually it's a really shitty one oh how
many beeps are in this video so far I
believe that is 2 okay
if someone says I need to visit the can
where they headed that is a loo correct
that is illusion yay what is the
pacifiers like a dummy like a thing good
you know you're doing really well
charlie how many points do I have seven
yes well maybe seven how many do I need
14 if you had a sub at school today what
does that mean uh substitute teacher
okay yeah yeah I have consumed quite a
lot of American media this was my
concern when I started making up this
list yeah there are probably a lot more
British slang words that Americans don't
know about than the other way around
because of the proliferation of American
media yeah what is it Raleigh these are
the more confusing ones the ones that
are already something in the UK and I'm
like well it's a trolley obviously
that's what a trolley is yeah
rubbish car it is an electrically
powered streetcar think of classic San
Francisco
there's the trolley car that goes down
nothing yeah I've been on one of those
well I still don't get it
good what is a douche it's a guy that is
not cool a douche
is a device for rinsing out the vagina
or anus yep why do you need one of the
just wash yourself in the shower I mean
sometimes you need that extra reach what
does a rag baby is it a baby that you
don't want anymore an ugly baby it's
just a doll
just like a rag doll right baby it
sounds like weird sounds so weird to my
British is what is a black top uh is
that a convertible car no if you hit
your head like really really bad and it
went like blank that's the most racist
thing I've ever heard you say like a
black eye like you had like a bruise the
black top is like asshole you could call
the street outside black top
oh okay if someone has horse sense they
are like since like I sense things like
spider sense
yes but for horses I can sense where
haze or know where horses are just means
you're smart pretty yeah why would you
pick horses is the one when or like
dolphins ants by language why not why
not make more sense a sense
good good fun a visit man okay what is a
butterface would you cool a person a
butterface yes okay like spotty person
or greasy teenager
butterface is usually used to refer to a
female who has a really amazing body but
her face dude that chick is a butter
face the iPad is dead now oh rhythm oh I
wasn't prepared to this I should have I
should have known this was coming
I just wasn't any particular dialects
from experience I know that when you
think American you just go straight for
southern accent so might as well just go
for a southern accent Charlie oh oh you
just had a Mosin potable jar walkin
Charlie is so cold lack which makes you
like cool did that sound seven - you did
that to some weird
yes good answer
caballo